Speaker 1: The failed former President Donald
J. Trump is now suggesting that Republicans
work to wreck the economy for the next two years
because that would be good for Trump in 2024. If
you could imagine a more depraved anti American
idea to benefit oneself politically than this,
I quite frankly can't think of it. I mean, if
if you put a gun to my head, which many of these
people would gladly do. I guess the worst scenario
would be allow or even encourage a terrorist
attack in order to place me as the person in
charge to unite the country after the attack to
increase my approval rating. If you say to me, Can
you think of something worse than let's wreck the
economy? It would probably be that. Let's take a
look at what Donald Trump posted to his platform,
Truth Social yesterday. Truth Central. Very,
very. There's a serious lack of truth here posted
in all capital letters, as Donald Trump often
does, saying, quote, Republicans can get almost
everything back that the old broken crow Mitch
McConnell and the real leader China centric Coco
Chow hit. By the way, he's he's referring to Mitch
McConnell's wife, Elaine Chao. That is his sort of
racist, xenophobic nickname for her. Stupidly gave
up to the Democrats over the last two years by
simply playing tough in the upcoming debt ceiling
negotiations. Trump is saying don't negotiate.
Allow the government to completely shut down.
Allow basic systems to fail, which will wreck
the economy, and then that'll help Republicans
in 2024. That's what Trump is saying. You have to
read between the lines here, and it's pretty easy
to figure figure out what he's saying. With the
right negotiators, like all of those involved the
other night on both sides for speaker. It will be
a beautiful and joyous thing for the people of our
country to watch Make America Great Again. Trump
thinks the American people would enjoy watching
basic services go unfunded due to political
maneuvering because it would be good TV. I mean,
the depravity here is one level, but actually,
I want to put that aside for a moment. Put aside
for a moment the immorality, the depravity, the
lack of ethics of this idea of ruin, the economy,
so that then Trump can swoop in in 24 and say,
look, you need to be back and I'll fix all of
this right away. Put it aside for a second.
I actually believe it's bad political strategy.
The long term consequences of a damaged economy,
I believe, outweigh the short term political
gain. It takes a long time and a huge amount of
resources to recover from an act of deliberately
screwing up the economy for two years and forget
about would it be irreparable? Let's concede it's
reparable. But you could be talking about years,
quite frankly, if you were to say, let's unite
and let's not do the debt ceiling if and when
it comes to be necessary. If we need stimulus
because of some crisis, let's not do it. If we
need funding for a natural disaster, let's
not do it on and on and on and on. Right.
I actually believe that the damage you do will
reach far beyond the two year term that you think
would basically be compartmentalize nicely to
help you in 2024 because deliberately wrecking the
American economy in order to win future elections.
Of course, it's unethical. Of course it lacks
integrity. Of course, it's a total abandonment
of the principles and their principles. Give me
a break. It's an abandonment of the principles
they claim to to to value. And of course,
it harms society in the short run, but it's bad
in the long run. And as a result, it's also not
a good idea for the for the Republican Party.
Now, Trump views erect economy as a key to his
election in 2024. He expects that Kevin McCarthy
is going to honor some kind of commitment to wreck
the economy to Trump. That would be insane if it
is the case and they need to be held accountable
if they do that. Now, let's be honest. If if
we. If nothing else, I'm honest with all of you.
If we are honest, even when Republicans don't
say it or don't realize it, their actions have
been disastrous for the economy for decades now.
That's just the reality. Trickle down economics,
where you cut taxes for the rich to raise the tide
for all boats. Does work. Flat out doesn't work.
We've had economists on. We've looked at the data,
just doesn't work. And so Republicans would never
say we're going to cut taxes on the rich to wreck
the economy. Now, they might even think it helps
the economy, but it doesn't. So the policy has
been bad for the economy for a very long time.
Reagan exploded spending while cutting taxes. It's
been policy for a very long time. Bush started two
wars, created the Department of Homeland Security
and TSA while giving tax cuts to the rich.
Come on. It's the same thing. Trump added
trillions in debt while giving tax cuts to
the rich. This has been what they've done for
decades. But now Trump is just openly saying,
Let's screw it up, let's screw it up. And
then Americans will figure out how much
they want Republicans in 2024. It's absolutely
disgusting, almost as disgusting as the very
ugly war between Lauren Boebert and Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. Let's talk about that next.
It's a new year. Many of us are trying to make
new positive changes here. Something really
simple that could be a game changer. Our sponsor,
Athletic Greens. Every day I take a scoop of AG
one. I get 75 high quality vitamins, minerals and
Whole Foods sourced ingredients to last me all day
long. This way I just know my nutritional bases
are covered for the entire day. It has everything
I want and that's important to me. Rather than
doing the individual supplements and vitamins or
whatever, I don't want to do any of that. Okay? AG
One is the simplest way to just get everything I
want for my nutritional foundation each day. AG
One is also a great bang for your buck. You're
going to end up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and minerals.
So save some money, make your life easier. Just
a scoop of AG one. I love the travel packs,
which let me take AG one. Wherever I go.
I have the big pack of AG one at home
and when you go to athletic green, XCOM slash
Pacman, you'll get five free travel packs plus
a free year supply of vitamin D, which I used
during the winter. The link is down below.